- Oh no!
- Shit, shit, shit.
I don't know.
They're both really good!
- I'm trying to tap
back into my childhood,
and I'm just coming up with
bad middle school memories.
- Well I think this tastes like heaven,
because Thin Mints are my
favorite Girl Scout Cookies
of all time.
- Oh, for days! For fucking days!
Thin Mints.
- There's like that minty kick to it.
(disapproving mumble)
- No.
- Nope.
- The chocolate is more synthetic.
- This inside is just like chalky.
- I think this one's a Thin Mint.
(bell dings)
(buzzer)
What?
- We're right?
- I know we're right.
You don't need to tell me I'm right.
I know I'm right.
- We're right.
- Do they teach you the
correct way to eat a Tagalong
in the Girl Scouts?
- The way I ate it was I
ate all the chocolate first,
and then I would like
the peanut butter out,
and then I would eat the cookie.
- There's a good ratio
between the peanut butter
and chocolate.
- That's just stale!
No.
(questioning expression)
- The peanut butter is
like a little more chalky,
whereas this one's creamier.
- This one's more of a wafer.
- This one's the Tagalong.
(bell dings)
- I'm gonna go with the
dark in the middle too.
(buzzer)
- Ooh, by the looks of it,
they look almost identical.
I would say that the only thing different
is the darkness in chocolate.
- That doesn't look good.
- And the circle, where did the circle go?
- No merit badge here.
- Oh!
- Fuck, that's good too.
- I like this one a little bit more.
- You know, I really just
can't tell anything anymore.
- I wait all year for
the Girl Scout Cookies,
and now knowing that I
can't tell the difference
is pretty crushing to me.
- I think those ones are real too.
(buzzer)
- What?
- I'm going left!
- I'm going right.
(bell dings)
- Damn it!
My Team Leader would be so pissed at me!
- This was great!
- I lost hard.
- Yeah, I'm surprised that
I got the Samoas wrong.
- What the fuck are these?
I knew it was Keebler.
- All the best cookies are
delivered by tiny people.
- I think after this
I can say that I will buy any
of the grocery store versions
besides the Thin Mints.
- Those fake Tagalongs, those
Fake-alongs, were really good.
- I feel like I would rather
buy the Girl Scout Cookie,
so I could contribute and be part of this
really amazing thing
that has so much history.
- Now I feel bad.